une des plus grandes découvertes
archéologiques du 20e siècle est un faux
[Musique]
écoutez bien ça l'histoire c'est celle
de joe dawson
on est au début du 20e siècle il se rend
dans une ferme pas très loin de perdre
aw et là ils creusent et découvre des
ossements humains
ils y retournent ils en découvrent
d'autres et qu'est ce qu'ils voient mais
il pense qu'il a trouvé le chaînon
manquant entre l'homo habilis et l'homme
de néandertal il trouve que c'est
vraiment fondamentales comme découvertes
et en 1912 il se rend devant le parterre
de scientifiques pour démontrer sa
grande théorie on crie au génie l'homme
de piltdown permet de prouver la théorie
de charles darwin qui l'a exposé dans
l'origine des espèces
à la mort de choses dans ce n'est son
fameux homme de paix all down commence a
soulevé beaucoup de questions on se
demande si c'est un vrai il ya des
anatomiste allemand qui vont prendre le
squelette grande spécifiquement et
qu'ils vont réaliser que c'est un
mélange d'ossements humains et d'os
d'orangs outans de sage
plus fort encore dans les années 40 et
dans les années 50 on commence à faire
une datation au carbone 14 et le crâne
qui devait être cinq cent mille ans plus
vieux que l'homme de néandertal en fait
large de 500 ans
c'est un homme médiévale l'homme de
piltdown tout ça est faux faux archi
faux
finalement on peu fourvoyé tout le monde
même la communauté scientifique
[Musique]